bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france le gouvernement a
raison
selon vous de questionner d'interroger
la laïcité d'ouvrir le débat
ah oui moi je pense que c'est très
important de le faire parce que
certaines populations qui est en attente
de réponse et il y a aussi toute une
jeunesse qui manque de pédagogie et qui
a vraiment besoin de s'exprimer
et avec cette expression nous verrons
aussi toutes les locaux et 11 peut-être
par rapport au mot laïcité
donc c'est très important pour moi que
ces états généraux aient lieu
aujourd'hui la laïcité à la française
qu'est ce que c'est pourquoi est ce que
visiblement elle suscite
l'incompréhension
alors je pense qu'il ne faut pas dire
laïcité à la française parce que
justement cela perturbe le discours nous
avons une grande pratique de la laïcité
puisque nous avons mis en place cette
loi 1905
c'est une loi qui a permis la séparation
et j'ai beaucoup aimé ce matin quand des
baignades ruiz a dit que ce n'était pas
une loi d'opposition mais bien une loi
de séparation des églises et de l'état
et je pense que nous manquons de
pédagogie car on a toujours fait une
définition donner une définition de la
laïcité qui est contre contre contre et
qui est plus une possibilité de
respecter le citoyen les citoyens que
nous sommes de montrer que la loi de la
république est plus importante que les
lois des différentes religions et nous
parlons souvent de vivre ensemble c'est
peut-être par soit devenu un peu une
expression j'oserais dire tarte à la
crème mais c'est plutôt vivre dans un
espace commun et cet espace commun c'est
notre république et d'autres républiques
en france elle est laïque et bago jr
auprès de la jeunesse
c'est la jeunesse que vivent ces états
généraux tout à fait tout à fait je
pense que c'est vraiment la jeunesse et
j'ai bien aimé ce qu'a dit la ministre
qui a dit nous allons essayer en toute
transparence grâce à cette plateforme
de mettre en avant les 10 20 points qui
sont des points d'accord pas mettre
toujours en avant les points de
désaccord et ça c'est important
alors parmi les critiques que l'on
entend il ya la suivante la laïcité est
un pilier de la france elle ne doit pas
déboucher sur un champ de bataille c'est
le danger aujourd'hui que ces
discussions qui vont s'ouvrir jusqu'à
l'été alors c'est le danger parce que on
mélange aussi le texte qui n'est
d'ailleurs pas tout à fait voter puisque
il ya eu la première lecture à
l'assemblée la première lecture au sénat
sur le respect des principes
républicains qui est une loi plus mr un
anti une anti radicalisation anti l
intégrisme en tout genre là on parle
vraiment de laïcité dans le sens où
c'est une possibilité de diffuser tout à
l'heure de vivre en commun dans le
respect que les citoyens se respecte et
ça c'est important d'avoir une vraie
pédagogie parce qu'on se rend compte que
dans les écoles s'est achevée lire en a
des tas d'exemples qui montrent qu'il y
a des choses que l'on a pu le droit de
dire que l'on n'a plus le droit
d'enseigner et ça ce n'est pas normal et
c'est pas la laïcité à la française
c'est simplement la laïcité qui permet
une émancipation une construction de
chacune et chacun
la laïcité c'est un sujet de patients la
ministre chargée de la société marlène
schiappa l'a reconnu elle même est ce
qu'il peut donc sortir de ces débats de
ces échanges à une forme de consensus
sur la question
alors j'espère que la médiation
justement sur cette plateforme va être
efficace pour que ce ne soit pas des
lieux d'un des petit on va dire jusque
qui n'aimait pas jusqu'aux insultes mais
vraiment des lieux de construction
je pense que l'éducation nationale va
prendre sa part mais là je dirais que
c'est un peu tardif dans le calendrier
parce que les jeunes qui vont retourner
à l'école vont penser à leur examen
et j'ai beaucoup aimé carte blanche aux
associations l'association je suis
présidente donc participera dans toutes
ses possibilités à cette plateforme à
ces débats à ces tables rondes dans
différents lieux parce que c'est ça
aussi c'est faire boule de neige et
boule de neige dans la pédagogie pas
dans la critique
moi aussi je pourrais dire on aurait dû
peut-être faire ces états généraux avant
on peut toujours dire mais il faut être
aussi optimiste et voir le verre à
moitié plein plutôt que le verre à
moitié vide
sur quoi pourrait devrait selon vous
débouchez ces états généraux
malin c'était sûr vraiment des points
communs parce que ce matin voyez j'ai
écouté tous les intervenants donc ce
soit catherine fourest et la ruine ou
gaspard koenig etc
on voit qu'il y a des différences mais
il ya aussi des points communs dde les
principes puisque la laïcité c'est un
principe juridique mais c'est aussi
politique c'est un choix d'humaniste de
donc là c'est la laïcité à la française
et ça doit amener un apaisement une
facilité de se comprendre et une
éducation du citoyen faut vraiment
comprendre que la laïcité permet permet
tout j'allais dire d'être agnostique
d'être athée de pratiquer d'avoir la foi
d'aller au culte de ne pas y aller mais
de partager les lois de la république et
un grand respect des uns des autres
et aujourd'hui quand vous voyez que
certaines choses ne peuvent pas être dit
que certaines choses on ne peut pas
construire on se dit qu'il y à vraiment
vraiment un gros retard au niveau de la
pédagogie
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation sur arte france françoise
laborde
je rappelle que vous êtes présidente de
l'association égale égalité laïcité
euros